[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to gamespot's
pre-show for
summer game first aka the summer kiwis
i'm lucy james
joining me today is tamar hussein hello
all praise goes to jeff keely
and jordan mermaid what's up are we
worshiping
jeff keeley now is that the end thing
jeff keely
is our game god of summer you must
sacrifice
your favorite game to him
okay so i didn't i had money on tam
being the first person to discuss elder
ring jordan but i think technically it
was you
um but we'll talk about elder ring in a
second uh we are going to be talking
about what we hope to see from the show
what we know
is going to be announced and any wild
card predictions we might have
so in terms of the show itself it's
gonna be roughly hour and a half to two
hours judging by what jeff has said on
twitter there's gonna be
30 plus games uh including some games
that have uh that are continuously
updated so we know things like among us
are going to be there
and some news on the new card season but
there are going to be
12 world premieres which are very
exciting um there's also
musical guests and giancarlo esposito
too which i'm very excited for but it's
so weird to see
you know gus spring at a gaming event
but anyway i hope he's the musical guest
i would be doing you never know that'd
be so cool
look i've got it i've got to get it um
out there at the beginning of the show
very very disappointed that there are no
muppets
um was that confirmed did they actually
say that yeah
yeah yeah jeff jeff tweeted out about
you know managing expectations
and said that like just yeah
no muppets this year which is very sad
to me because i always thought they were
a great little addition to every time
interestingly though interesting though
he took the opportunity to say there's
not going to be muppets to manage
expectations he did not take the
opportunity to say there will be no
elden ring
to manage expectations thus there
is a chance there is a chance everyone
thank you okay until
no come on we can let's talk about eldon
ring
why why are you giving in to him you
know that damn just wants to take over
the stream and talk about elderly if i
don't let him talk about eldon ring now
he's gonna keep bringing it up until we
do talk about it and honestly
i am also at the point where i just i
just want elderbring
to be shown tam why do you think it's
going to be
today at summer game first and not like
microsoft
because my fingers are tingling my
my my genitals are tingling every part
of me is tingling
and you know when that happens that
happens when i can feel something
is going to happen in the energy of the
world around from software
i'm in tune with sure you haven't just
had are you sure just have too much
coffee
because that also sounds like i haven't
had too much coffee
there was uh some substances that i took
it's fine it's just loads of sugar um so
i am hopped up on sugar
but i feel it i feel it this is all my
time playing souls games
and bloodborne games i don't know i just
feel it man
and if it doesn't happen i cannot begin
to explain
the sadness i will feel but i'm i'm
believing i tweeted out earlier to
everyone you know let's manifest
together
and that tweet has been quote tweeted
many times and retweeted
i feel like the golden ring community
right now is like
i'm goku and they're giving me their
spirit energy so we can spirit bomb an
elden ring trailer towards uh
the community i i don't know i just
it feels right man it feels right if it
doesn't happen i will cry
on stream but what if and what if it's
not here today
and what if it's at microsoft on sunday
i mean i'll take it so like i'm i'm
gonna leave if it doesn't show up today
i'm gonna leave sad
but i still have hope for microsoft
because
we did an interview with big phil
spencer aka big phil
aka philly um
and he said i was playing it i've played
it which means
there's a decent chance after he
finished playing it he was like can we
have this for e3 and then miyazaki was
like yeah you can have this for you free
um so there's a decent chance
there's a decent chance if it doesn't
show up at microsoft
then we've got a problem then we've got
a big big problem
that is when i'm gonna be like holy moly
something's bad
and i will like begin walking into the
sea and you'll never see me again
i mean first of all to begin
unpacking all of that but i mean
specifically why do you think it's going
to be a
jeff's show today like is that is it
like
you know you know french friendship
ended with phil spencer jeff keeley is
now my best friend
i feel like uh jordan mentioned it
earlier if jeff is going for anything to
give him
like a big punch with the the uh summer
games first
trailers he is going for elder he knows
he knows what people want he's a crowd
pleaser he's a people pleaser
he has probably like day after game
awards
or like the day after game awards where
sakura won the award for game of the
year
he was probably in miyazaki's dms being
like how about hooking me up with the
trailer for elden ring
and if he wasn't i bet he spent that
entire
year up until this point just constantly
being miyazaki's reply guy on whatever
discord server they're in together
just being like hook me up hook me up
sort me out
me out i love the idea of me jeff and
phil just breaking into the office at
the exact same time
like please give us the elden ring
trailer
um also i mean
yeah i would love to see it today but i
i think it'll be xbox i am very very
happy to be proven wrong
but i i believe like something in my in
my heart of hearts tells me it's going
to be xbox but
let's talk a little bit about we do know
we're going to be seeing today so
in terms of musical performances uh
japanese breakfast
weezer and the sonic symphony is going
to be doing a special orchestral
thing for sonic's 30th anniversary which
is quite nice because i think
one of my favorite things that uh always
about the um one of my favorite things
about the game awards
are the those big orchestral
performances they do the red dead
redemption one in particular from a
couple years ago and the big game of the
year medley from 2018 was
unbelievable so i'm genuinely very
excited about those because it's a mix
of like
stuff in games but also just you know
weezer is there too
uh jordan what do you think are you
talking about musicals
is that too uh for the musical stuff or
or
the special guests like jeff goldblum
giancarlo esposito um and i've already
said no muppets
i say i i'm there for the music sonic
like sonic
like his games have been admittedly a
little hit or miss
like over the past decade or
two but the music always hits the music
for sonic always hits so
to get an orchestral version of that oh
it's gonna be so good an experience i
can't wait for it
i honestly i mean i i never really grew
up being a sonic
gal so i don't think it's gonna have as
much emotional meaning
to me as it will for you but i'm very
glad you're excited about it
um let's talk about the games then so
we've got 30
plus games and so here's some of the
stuff that we know about let's kick it
off with
among us so definitely like
i judging from what i could see on
twitter just looks like there's gonna be
a new color
maroon um but also the jeff mask is back
um and i think as part of a twitch drop
um
time when was the last time you played
among us
uh i think i played it last time i
played it was when i played it with you
where i got the imposter
i was cast as the imposter seven times
in a row
so uh to the point where people just
immediately knew that i was the imposter
even before the game had begun
um so i want to say i had the best
experience with among us
what i am interested in seeing is
whether jeff will use the word sauce
is jeff keeley gonna say the word sauce
in front of
hundreds and thousands of gamers i've
got my fingers crossed for it i hope for
it
uh on top of that i think it's i'm i'm
kind of
i'm glad that among us is there because
it's been one of the defining
games of the last year and a half and
there's a massive community of people
that are
keen so like even a simple color uh
reveal and the jeff mask is just enough
to fill the meme factory
for us and that's ultimately what's the
most important thing about the summer
games fest
memes and elder ring but mostly memes
but also ordering mostly out of the ring
i was gonna say i mean speaking of elder
ring memes poor jeff did do
a an ama on reddit and every single
question pretty much was a quote from
the elden ring trailer
i see you from my all
no i agree like i i really enjoy seeing
updates for things like among us
you know on a stage like uh summer game
first or
the the yeah i almost called them the
kiwis because that's just what i call
them the game awards
because it's just nice to see sort of
recognition for games that are
continuing
and like providing new updates and stuff
and so i haven't played among us in a
while jordan
is this going to be regardless of what
this is never touched
among us i'm excited for i'm excited for
the people who
like among us but it's just it's it's
just just not my
type of game it's not like a cup of tea
i can speak
wow you're trying to trying to appeal to
the two brits in the room i like it
uh we also know that there's gonna be
call of duty season
four so this is kind of hot on the heels
of uh
vgc reporting yesterday the card's gonna
be skipping e3
um but card season four there will be
some information about it
today at summer game first um as well to
see the world series of war zone
captains unveiled
i don't know what that means i assume
it's an esports thing
i i think so it is an esports thing but
like i
i don't know like i feel like they would
have used this opportunity to
to announce more um guest characters
like we had what was it rambo show up
and john mclean like why
i hope that they sneak in like a
surprise like
hey we've got vin diesel from
fast and furious is here in the war zone
and he's just like constantly doing
family equips with his uh
with his squad um like that would be
pretty cool but
yeah i think like call of duty war and
quality was on becoming the behemoth
that it is it makes
100 sense that it would show up
there is a there are a lot of people
that are keen to see what the next
iteration
of the uh warzone seasons brings to the
game and i'm one of them as someone who
kind of
plays passively warzone continues to be
doing interesting things it is the most
interesting thing that call of duty has
done in quite some time love it or hate
it
at least they're trying something
different with call of duty and i'm
super up for that
i hope they do lean into a bit more of
the weird experimental stuff that they
have been trying with the character
stuff and
the smaller events things so i'm eager
to see what the next season holds
jordan you still playing warzone i play
it on and off i mean
my battle royale of choice is apex
legends which i
feel i've made abundantly clear on many
of the shows that
we've played uh we've done but
i mean warzone is awesome i'm so
every time i play it i'm like yeah this
is call of duty is
so good and it's been interesting to be
like man it's gonna
i hope that it's there for no other
reason that we get a battlefield trailer
uh new call of duty like trailer
announcement thing
and then presumably halo infinite during
the xbox bethesda
uh thing because it's been a very long
time since we've been like yo we're
getting
halo call of duty and battlefields all
in the same year
all at the same time it's like a
throwback to like early 2000s
yeah or like maybe 10 years ago at kind
of the apex of uh
360 era when just all of that stuff was
coming out and it was all sort of like
the halcyon days of first-person
shooters so yeah we're definitely gonna
get
some some word on card season four
but interesting we're gonna get a brand
new game announcement
that they've already teased and has sort
of already leaked because it was in like
source code of a website
but new game from gearbox um be
be chaotic great.com um
kind of everyone kind of assumes it's
going to be a borderlands thing
um because someone in the website code
found the name
wonderlands so jordan you are our
resident
borderlines fan um are you excited for
more games in that universe
depends really really depends like
i like i was one of those people that i
was a fan of borderlands 3
but even i could tell that i'm like man
it's kind of just doing what borderlands
2
did like seven to eight years prior it's
just kind of just doing it again
and it hasn't really evolved in any way
so my hope is that if this wonderland is
connected to borderlands which it very
well looks like it is
what are they doing to change it how are
they evolving are they still going for
the
four character structure is it more you
can create your own
characters it's still a linear campaign
through levels or is it more of an open
world adventure
what are they doing how is it different
because if it's exactly the
same as borderlands 2 and borderlands 3
i'm i'm not
sure if i'm going to be excited for that
i kind of want a little bit more out of
the borderlands franchise going forward
i mean because i mean i think my
favorite borderlands adjacent thing was
tales from the borderlands right and so
that was an interesting story told in a
very
different way but still set in their
universe tam you and i played
borderlands 3 together with
a mix of results gun play was fun i
think just the
the joke sort of grated after a while
yeah you be tempted to dip your toe back
in
should be quiet be quiet be quite quite
be quite pleased um
i could be tempted to go back in um but
like i said yeah
i need it like jordan said i need it to
be something different right now
um i feel like the borderlands franchise
needs to
this is going to sound mean but it i
kind of
believe it it needs to grow up a bit and
i'm not saying like become
dour and and like you know you know
uh have no fun with it there are ways to
have fun and a personality i just feel
like it feels like a very
year 2000 game um and mechanically it's
very sound i think there's there's
interesting ways that you can take
what's there and spin it into something
different um but yeah i could definitely
go
back into borderlands i'm keen to go
back into borderlands i loved playing
all of those games it's just the and the
world is like fascinating to me and
really beautiful but
anytime dialogue is spoken i'm just like
please please stop um how dare you say
that tiny tina's in those games and her
dialogue is wonderful
it's wonderful for like five minutes and
then she carries on for another three
hours and you're like all right
all right how dare you
listening i can i am one of those people
who can take on leave borderlands i
remember playing borderlands 1 and
enjoying it um
i've played like half of two didn't
really get into it but then we finished
three
and i think that gameplay loop and the
fact that there were
however many bajillions of guns i think
that was what the the marketing
tagline was i thought that was really
fun and i enjoyed the way i could spec
my character
and like the progression and stuff but i
agree i think the
the humor grated on me after a while but
i think the world itself is so cool and
i think a lot of the mechanics are just
perfectly right so i'm very interested
to see more of what they could do with
borderlands do we think
i know there is going to be some kind of
gearbox panel this weekend too
do you think they're going to show all
of their cards here or save it for the
weekend
and what do we think about the
borderlands movie if we're gonna see any
of that today
oh my god it completely opened that up
to the floor
oh that makes a lot of sense that they
had actually
yeah they might actually like talk more
about the movie today
and like tease that they're going to
announce a new game like
at their panel i could actually see that
that would
of course we've also like come off of
the e3 2019 where it was like oh kingdom
hearts is going to be at every single
conference across the entire thing so
maybe gearbox is just like we can do the
same thing we're just as cool as kingdom
hearts we're just going to show a new
wonderlands trailer at every single
conference this year
yeah but except i hope yeah they don't
do what kingdom hearts did and
remember that was it microsoft's
performance they played the version
with was it like the sound effects were
really loud or there were no sound
effects and it was really weird
wasn't it wasn't didn't it used like a
was it the one that had the
watermark on the frozen section wasn't
that from e3 yes
yeah yeah yeah that wasn't that yeah
that was like a yeah okay
some random devex walking was such a
that was such a long e3 for that reason
alone it was like wow we're seeing
another
kingdom hearts trailer oh my god never
do that again
any developers no one should do that i i
i think that they they sho they tease
they tease the game here and like show
like maybe five or ten seconds of it
and then go come back uh during our
press conference to see more of this
and the movie um and then that's pretty
much what we get which will be enough
yeah i think so i mean i still can't
believe that it's like is it jamie lee
curtis
and kate blanchett are in it it just
doesn't feel
is it i mean i can see it i could see
jackson's isn't it
and uh kevin hart and kevin hart is
roland i think
right yeah i'm not making this up like
it's like it's like surprisingly
like good polls across the board but
like
putting people into roles i'm like i
never would have considered that for
them
yeah it's definitely not like an uber
bowl production
we've actually got some it looks like
it's got some money and some clout
behind it so
it could be good or or whatever paul
anderson
w i don't know which one it is paul
thomas
it's no is it thomas or um
i would love to see what he would do
with something like resident evil on
monster hunter but now alas it's uh paul
w
s anderson um how did we get here
borderlands okay so yeah we definitely
know there's gonna be borderlands
uh we're also gonna see first game play
from evil dead
the game which i'm kind of excited about
because
evil dead is one of those movies that
like
and also there's this kind of
renaissance of
b horror movies right now as well i'm
guessing dead by daylight
um and all of the crossovers that
they've had
are you excited to see any more of evil
dead the game
yeah i i think evil dead is one of those
classic franchises that is due
a good game and i hope it kind of is
such a good universe as well and
i didn't hasn't asked shown up in a
bunch of other things now at this point
like
yeah he was in something fairly recently
and once i feel like his character was
in fortnite
maybe possibly i mean at this point i've
been in fortnight
so yeah yeah
um but like yeah he's i think he could
make a really cool
like uh action game even the survival
horror i style action game
um with with evil dead and give it like
its own unique little identity and a
cool little personality that's like
scary and creepy and kind of grotesque
but also very light-hearted
um so yeah i'm definitely excited to see
see that evil dead game i hope it's good
if it's just like mediocre then i'm just
gonna be like no
i can never hear the word mediocre
without hearing the mad max
which is yeah so that's in my in my head
as soon as you said mediocre that's
where
it went uh we've got just under five
minutes before we will throw over to
jeff and the summer game first show so
very quickly
um do we think we're going to see some
far cry 6 here today
um i know giancarlo esposito is um
there i i guess i'm not sure what he's
doing because usually they would be
hosting awards or something like
presenting an award but i don't think
that's the point of summer game first
so do we think he's there to introduce
like a new thing for far cry
or is he just there for a laugh jordan
it makes the most sense for him to be
introducing far cry unless like
at the same time that he's been doing
far cry someone else is like yo this
actor's really dope let's get him for
our game which i mean maybe
i it's one of those things where i'm
like it makes sense for him to be
introducing another
trailer for far cry 6 but at the same
time i'm like why would ubisoft want to
showcase something for far cry 6 when
they have
ubisoft forward like in a few days
and they would theoretically be
showcasing far cry 6 there
i maybe far cry 6 is going to be the
kingdom hearts 3
of summer 2021
i feel like i feel like you bring him on
and like like i said in a previous
stream ubisoft is still
chasing the vosh like uh do you know the
definition of insanity moment
i feel like what they might do is show
some sort of like
really intense scene where he's
delivering a speech like that and either
show that in in engine and then have him
come out and be like
it's me i did that or they have him live
on stage do like a reading of it
to be like like less let's put less pot
there like
the the uh the intensity on the audience
as as they're watching
um and then giancarlo esposito does his
thing he acts in front of everyone does
a bit of theater
and everyone goes well that was cool and
they don't actually show much of far cry
they just use his star power to promote
the game
um i would love to see that let's you
want him to actually like
intro as his character yeah
star wars battlefront 2 with the main
character for that uh
i can't remember his name uh j
jaina that sounds uh i'm not sure
um but no i thought oh um
they would maybe do something like
similar to what they did with mirage
at um game awards a couple years ago oh
yeah roger craig smith doing the live
actions and maybe maybe do something on
that
or maybe it's an elaborate ted lasso
crossover because the main character in
far cry 6 is called
danny rojas who is the life guide
so i really just want that to happen uh
we've got a couple of minutes
why do we think jeff goldblum is there
because i think i think jeff
keeley tweeted that like all of the
hosts are kind of involved in games
so watch the video games
comes to stage does does his does his
like uh aloof
uh ladies and gentlemen uh we are here
at c
well it's elden ring
yeah and then he's the boss in elden
ring and then
and then he like he's like the new
patches he's the new patches
you don't get betrayed by it's jeff
goldblum
he's like yeah oh a wandering one
i've got some special waves for you when
you like them
like that dammit i love it i love this
idea
all things all things come around um
it's the circle of life it's the elden
ring of life we've just got we've got
just over a minute
so very quickly going to come to you
both um
not elden ring and not hollow knight
silk song i'm taking those off the table
what do you really hope to see
at summer game fest today jordan go
uh what is that game called callisto
protocol
what is the it's the sequel to the pub g
universe the horror game
gosh calypso cliffs though something
like that callisto i can't even remember
its name but it looks so cool and i want
to see gameplay that would be dope
tam oh i want to see i want to see
big phil on stage i want to see a big
photo on stage
just being like hello everyone here's
some halo and then it's a couple of
seconds of halo come back
to the microsoft press conference where
we'll show you more of this video game
called halo
so i'll be i'd be happy with that that's
fair
i i i want to see something from bioware
mass effect or dragon age either or
would love both
um so we will be back here after summer
game fest
to discuss all the biggest announcements
and world premieres uh so you won't want
to miss it
and now we're going to throw over to
jeff keely and summergame first 2021
i told you we'd start right on time
hello everyone around the world and
welcome to summer game fest kickoff live
presented by prime gaming i'm jeff keely
and buckle up
because we've got a big show for you
filled with new game announcements world
premieres
updates on the games you play every day
some surprises
and special guests including jeff
goldblum giancarlo esposito
and performances by weezer japanese
breakfast
and the sonic the hedgehog symphony
orchestra yes that's really a thing
now like a great video game there may be
some twists along the way today
and just wait until you see what we have
planned for the end game
that is all i'm allowed to tell you
right now
this is just the start of a big summer
game fest weekend of news and updates
for fans
including live streamed events from
publishers like xbox and bethesda
square enix ubisoft and more you can
head right now to summergamefest.com to
track all the events
and believe me there is a lot of great
stuff coming your way
but today we kick things off with a big
90-minute cross-industry showcase
meant to put platforms and rivalries
aside
we will have updates and news for you no
matter if you play on nintendo switch
pc playstation or xbox the biggest games
in the world will be here
and some of the smallest ones too made
by emerging voices and developers from
around the world
who represent what's next thank you so
much
for tuning in and kicking off video game
summer
well let's begin with a brand new game
announcement
you're about to see the world premiere
of the next great adventure
from gearbox and 2k
fate
it soars on the wind it rises
from the grave it stops the ocean floor
you cannot hide from fate
but you can make your own
[Music]
[Music]
tiny tina's wonderlands is official and
joining us now is tiny tina herself
ashley brush hey ash hi
what's up baby how you doing great to
have you here uh
so i think the big question everyone's
gonna have is what is wonderland what
can you tell us about it it's a great
question
it's uh it's a high fantasy take on a
looter shooter as you saw and um
if you're a fan of borderlands you'll
probably recognize
some fantasy elements inspired by
assault on dragon keep which was the
borderlands 2 dlc that was beloved by
the devs and so this kind of inspired
wonderlands
now i think the the elephant in the room
is is this a borderlands game is it not
how does it relate
so it actually isn't it's its own
standalone game um
and people that love borderlands are
going to find lots of elements to love
about wonderlands but it's its own thing
tiny tina's got her own thing going on
now um
so it's got its own mechanics or spell
casting
you can customize your character this
time which is super exciting and
um yeah so if you love borderlands
you're gonna find stuff to love in this
and if you've never played a borderlands
game this is a great place to start okay
well
tiny tina gets her own game which is
fantastic what is her
her role why does she get her own game
so she is your bunker master
um she's kind of guiding the narrative
and changing it on a dime if she wants
um and she's just taking your cast of
characters uh which is amazing cast
um through this wacky world uh and she's
taking you on
an adventure to defeat the dragon lord
who is that i don't know
you'll have to play and i wonder who
plays the dragon because you can point
the voice cast including you in this
which is awesome so
feels like such a a big experience um so
this was a bit of a tease announcing
it's out there
um when will we find out more about this
game um
hopefully this summer um and
you can find out a lot more at
playwonderlands.com if you'd like
okay um but yeah just stay tuned for
updates all right coming early 2022. so
look forward to next year ash thank you
so much for joining us in person
thanks for having me really appreciate
it and uh we'll see more later this
summer on that game
all right well uh now it is time for
another brand new game announcement this
one
you probably are not expecting a classic
90s franchise is coming back to life
as a grid-based tactical strategy title
for steam on pc
this is an insanely fun trailer i hope
you'll enjoy
[Music]
marco
[Music]
fio
[Music]
so
[Music]
okay we have another big announcement
for you from a surprise
guest but it's well past 3 a.m their
time
so don't worry we chatted earlier and
i'm very excited to share this with you
right now
hello mystery guest
hello dear mr kojima
it is so good to see you thank you for
joining us
uh from tokyo uh first of all i just
want to ask
how are you doing how are you feeling
how are things right now uh over there
in japan
well we certainly hope that you're going
to get your vaccine soon um
let me ask you as a creator how has this
past year
impacted you
[Music]
know
[Music]
[Music]
a
foreign
well i know we are all very curious
about what the next era
of hideo kojima entertainment is going
to be um
i don't know how much you can say but
can you give us any sense of of kind of
where your mind's at right now what
you're thinking about some of the themes
or the ideas
all right fair enough i tried uh well
mr kojima honestly i i really do
appreciate you making the time to stop
by and just
say hello to everyone uh we miss you and
we can't wait to see what you're working
on
uh next so um thank you
ah jeff jack one more thing
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
there you have it death stranding
director's cut
finally confirmed i hope i make it into
the director's cut
i'm told the full reveal is just weeks
away
stay tuned all right next it's my honor
to welcome to summer game fest a
legendary actor who dedicated a whole
episode of his disney plus show to
exploring the world of gaming
and has been in games like call of duty
black ops 3 and we're thrilled to have
him here at summer game fest
jeff goldblum how are you my friend
thank you so much joffrey or
j giaff or sorry
i think it's j i think it's jeffrey hey
maybe it's jeff hi hi jeff
uh thank you so much sincerely for
having me here i'm thrilled to be here
hey i was watching your show um and i
was
wondering uh if there might be some
video game
world premieres as you say uh and sure
enough
yeah uh uh there is there is
yes we do like our world premieres
around here any chance you uh brought
one with you today
well it's funny you should say that yes
you could say uh
yes i do uh if you don't mind i've uh
got something here i'm gonna read it on
this there's a little bit of a
teleprompter that they're putting up
here so i'm going to read something
because i don't want to get it wrong
i'm very meticulous about this so here's
a dramatic reading
of this game announcement ready i'm
going to make the game announcement
right now
hello i'm here to welcome you
to a very different world
it's going to elevate you to new heights
it's going to submerge you to new depths
maybe even challenge you to
control chaos
actually it's going to certainly
challenge you to control
chaos it's a world um
so-called evolved
take a look at the you guessed it
world premiere
we ignored all the warnings
forgot the lessons we abused
our power
[Music]
we played with genetics like uh
like it was a toy
[Music]
we weren't careful and now
ah here we are
[Music]
this is a very different world
[Music]
[Music]
all right this performer's new album
jubilee is out now and her book
crying in hmart is a new york times best
seller here now to perform glider from
the upcoming open world game
sable by raw fury and shed works it's
japanese breakfast
[Music]
it feels like everything is
feels like it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the things
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
god
[Music]
blinders
so beautiful thank you michelle uh sable
will be released on september 23rd this
year that's some news for you
and to learn more about this amazing
game watch the tribeca game showcase
that is tomorrow
where sable was named an official
selection of the legendary festival
now today is just the start of summer
game fest day of the devs with im8bit
and double fine will immediately follow
the live show today
and there are more events coming all
weekend and all month
including the xbox and bethesda games
showcase on sunday it's going to be a
good one
right now though we're thrilled to
announce the upcoming western release of
a spectacular 3d massively multiplayer
online role-playing game
welcome to the world of lost ark from
smile gate rpg
and amazon games
a lost ark is now
but a
once again the demons
have returned
[Music]
with roaring destruction
and waking nightmares
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
out of hope
we turn to myths
[Applause]
[Music]
sometimes when you play a game there's
that one thing in your inventory which
turned out to be far more useful than
you first realized
that's kind of like prime gaming if
you're an amazon prime member and most
of you probably are
you get a ton of gaming goodies every
month this month you can download
battlefield 4 and batman the telltale
series completely free for pc
and there are special in-game benefits
and perks in gta online
valorent apex legends and more that you
can unlock
it's awesome value and honestly this
kickoff show would not have been
possible without the prime gaming folks
believing in my vision
for a new way to bring you the news this
summer so head over to gaming.amazon.com
to check out all the perks and free
games
which change every month but you get to
keep them forever
okay right now i'm honored to be joined
by johanna ferris the new
gm of call of duty johanna it's so great
to have you
with us here on kickoff live everyone is
so excited about what call of duty's
been doing with all these seasons and i
know
uh looks like next week june 17th season
four
yes we're super excited we're super
honored to be here so thank you first
and foremost to that it's just such an
amazing time for call of duty
we're experiencing such transformational
growth and dynamism across the entire
brand you know from premium title
releases to everything we'll talk about
today
with with warzone with mobile with
esports so it's just
super incredible all the work and shout
out to everybody in the call of duty
family who makes it happen every
day yeah no you've been i mean i know
season three it was like you know rambo
die hard now who knows what's in store
for season four but you guys you know
continually update the game now with new
stuff uh season four
is coming next week what can you uh this
is first
info on it so what can you tell the fans
watching around the world yeah we're
stoked it's jam-packed with new content
across cold war and war zone you know
you've got new weapons we've got new
maps we've got
badass new operators i'm super excited
about the hijacked gulag we've got
expanded zombies content for everybody
who loves that part of
you know the gameplay experience so
we're thrilled and i'm excited to bring
it forward a little bit here today
i know we've got uh the first look world
premiere trailer of
season four so uh let's take a look at
that now
do what you are told and you get to live
you understand
i knew you were a smart one
secure the site cold war just turned
hard
we've located the satellite
raptor one my team's about to be overrun
oh my god that looks so fun and one week
away one week away
all right well uh let's move on to uh
you first joined activision to run uh
call of duty esports and we're gonna
talk a little bit now about uh
what is the world series of uh war zone
which is going to start
on june the 22nd uh first of all tell us
what is world series orizon yeah we're
super excited about it it's really a new
way
for us to highlight competitive call of
duty you know we've got great success
going with call of duty league and now
we've got
some of the biggest names in gaming
battling it out in verdansk
for what will be the biggest prize pool
in warzone
um since it's launched right so um we'll
talk a little bit about what that
entails but custom lobby experience is
150 player to a side squad so i'm stoked
to see how they uh kind of rally here in
verdansk
yes uh and coming up very soon june 22nd
uh
looks like looks like twitch rivals is
going to be a part of this yeah we are
honored to be in partnership with twitch
always right but
certainly here with world series of war
zone and partnering with twitch rivals
who's
already done so much to really put
competitive warzone on display so
couldn't be in better partnership there
and
we're excited to have everybody tune in
yes uh there is one thing though that
everyone has been talking about online
and that's uh who the captains are going
to be
uh for the structure of uh of the world
throughout at least for the first event
yeah um i understand we've uh
getting a little bit reveal here of who
some of the captains are yeah we love
the first five captains of the first of
many events to come
uh like i said these are huge
influencers and personalities
in call of duty and they also share our
passion for competitive call of duty
right they really believe
in the promise of world series of war
zone and to really level up what it
means to really battle it out so
uh couldn't be happier with some of
these names many of whom also hail from
the call of duty league family
um and i'm excited to see who kind of
takes the cake here we'll see
i was gonna say they're all be battling
out uh in just a couple weeks on twitch
rivals well it's really exciting uh
to see how much uh you know call of duty
is growing into this kind of year-round
experience for everyone with so much
more content so we can't wait to see
where you're gonna take it and i know
uh there is a big new mainline game
coming later this year too right
indeed indeed more details to share
later on but uh sledgehammer games is
you know gonna bring forward something
truly incredible so we're excited
all right we tried guys there will come
a time and a place for that all right
johanna thank you so much for joining us
we really
appreciate it all right we've got lots
of summer game fest kickoff to go
but right now we've got a surprise guest
joining us
my fellow canadian ryan reynolds hey
ryan
well thank you jeff and hello summer
game fest
now i look i know what you're thinking
and no i'm i'm not here to announce
i'm the star of eldon ring i think
instead no i'm making uh i'm telling you
to talk about good old-fashioned movies
you remember those things of course you
don't look um
i have a new movie coming out august
13th called free guy
and in this movie i play an npc
character uh in a popular open world
video game
until i break free and i realize that it
kind of sucks
to be a you know lonely background
character on an endless
walk cycle so now here's one of those
world premieres
it's a first ever look at our cast on
the big screen
this august and honestly it's been so
long i can't remember who's even in this
movie i didn't say that i'll cut that
out yeah i'll do it right now
my name is guy i thought i had
everything i needed
mondays am i right joe you said it guy
but then i met her put these on
oh my god what are these
trick glasses or something guy there is
no easy way to say this
this world it's a video game you're not
real
the guy responsible for this world is
going to destroy it
are we talking about god you've met god
yes he's an absolute troll
trolls exist we can save our world
but we have to fight together
that actually hurt my hand i have three
words for you
blue shirt guy this guy is outskilling
all these players i've never seen
anything like this
who the hell even knows who this blue
shirt guy is he's also really cute
the game wasn't even made for someone
like this
terminate them
nope
i can't die i'm never gonna die
that was fun seeing uh ninja pokey
jacksepticeye laser beam all those guys
who will be
in uh free guy uh ryan had to say it i
can't say it yet all right uh up next it
won multiple awards at the game awards
and among us
just keeps going now it's time to hear
from inner sloth
on what's coming next
[Music]
[Music]
lots of fun ahead and speaking of among
us
last year you may remember the very rare
jeff keely mask was available as a
twitch drop around the game awards
never to be seen again in fact i often
hear on twitter from people who get
booted from games with the mask because
uh
folks think they're hacked well never
fear today
the mask is back just head to twitch
connect your account and watch
15 minutes or more of kickoff live to
get your very own
jeff keeley mask once again and then it
goes back into the vault
i don't know what's going on all right
speaking of independent developers now
i'm very happy to welcome to summer game
fest
the head of indies at playstation a
legend in his own right who has some
exciting things to share
shuhei yoshida hi xu
thanks jeff hi everyone i'm shuhei
yoshida
head of playstation indies what i love
about working with independent
developers
are the new and unexpected games that
they create
which allows us to offer an array of
unique experiences for players
in my role as sony it's very exciting
to get to meet with these talented
studios
which sometimes can be one person or
small group of friends
to help nurture their ideas and bring
them to the playstation funds
one example is from finji who has been
working with greg
lobanov the developer of wonder song
to publish their new game chicory a
colorful tale
chico release today and give players a
chance to experience a coloring book
style world
where players use their painting powers
to explore
solve puzzles make friends and draw
on anything check out chikurya kara
futel on playstation
4 or playstation 5 after the show as
a huge source from games fun i
totally enjoyed the beautiful to the
action adventure south and sanctuary a
few years ago
the developers cast studios has been
hard at work on a new title
which i'm proud to present to you
sword and sacrifice
our sins will catch up with us
always
[Music]
i was given a second chance
i spoke the words
[Music]
i drank the mage paint
[Music]
i live now only to hunt
[Music]
mages
[Music]
i am a marked inquisitor
there aren't many others but together
[Music]
thank you and that's not all today we're
also able to share with you a brand new
trailer from the upcoming annapurna and
heart machine game
solar ash which is coming to playstation
later this year
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
that looks so so great can't wait to see
it later this year now this week there
is a ton of video game news but there's
also a big game launching across
console and pc chivalry 2 which brings
64-player multiplayer medieval battles
to life
sledgehammers swords axes you name it
and it comes from torren banner studios
in my hometown of toronto canada
here's a look at the launch trailer for
chivalry 2 which you can play
right now
any old women
[Music]
for every warrior there comes a time
when a moment
against steel and shields and we cry out
towards eternity
find yourself endless
ignite the fire of your soul
[Music]
another victory
for agatha
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
this month valorent from riot celebrated
its one year anniversary and starting
next monday june 14th
prime gaming members will get an
exclusive player card to celebrate the
one year anniversary
and a pity party spray through june 25th
this is all leading up to the release of
episode three of the game later this
month which will be celebrated with an
epic wwfest unlocked year one stream on
june 25th
but there will also be a new agent who
could it be
well here's your first very very
exclusive but very very quick tease
to whet your appetite with more to be
revealed later this month
during summer game fest
[Music]
i told you it was very very quick all
right our warring pmc factions face off
against each other in escape from tarkov
the popular multiplayer
first person shooter video game
developed by battle state games today
we've got an exclusive new look at the
streets of tarkov the new area of the
game
under development
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
surprise [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
when i was a kid the simulation games of
peter molyneux were some of my
favorites adding that extra salt on the
fries in the theme park to increase your
drink sales was so
devilish well many of the team members
behind those sim games went on to create
two point studios
and two point hospital well today we're
excited to share the first trailer for
their next two point simulation
two point campus
that first sight of the school gets the
scent of a leather-bound book
the faint clatter of knights jousting
well i
can't say i remember that part though it
wasn't like this in my
day you see campuses are forever
changing
nowadays education has to be fun
it can't be all work and no play and
quite right too
apparently the results speak to
themselves
academia has never been more appealing
more
dynamic more whatever this is
[Music]
today's campus is a place to live and a
place to
learn finally crafted by the sharpest
vibes that
money can buy though sometimes
you still can't get the stuff
yes these days it really does feel as
though
anything is possible
[Music]
so
two-point campus class is in session
2022
[Music]
this year i am thrilled to have netflix
as a part of summer game fest they have
been doing
an incredible job adapting games with
series like castlevania and the dota
anime
well there is a lot more coming and you
don't have to wait long to find out more
tomorrow i'm honored to be guest hosting
netflix's geeked week live stream with
mario takahashi and rahul kohli
you can expect the first clip of the
cuphead show
which spoiler alert this show is going
to be an
absolute sensation i can't wait for you
to see it
i'll also sit down with the team behind
arcane the league of legends animated
show coming later this year and we might
also have updates
on the witcher and the live action
resident evil series
geeked week is streaming live tomorrow
at 9 a.m pacific noon eastern
here's a little sneak peek
what is geek week netflix geek is
hosting
a free virtual event full of big news
exciting
first looks and the people who make the
shows and films you love
on netflix comics games
movies zombies animation
sci-fi fantasy
tuck in and join netflix geek for geeks
week
there's so much to get geeked about
we aren't done with netflix just yet
though coming up next is smite a
cross-play cross-platform game
that continues to do some pretty amazing
ip crossovers you may remember last
summer we announced the avatar the last
bender one
well as smite enters its ninth year it's
time to go
upside down
[Music]
come on
wow
[Music]
next up we announce a lot of games on my
shows but i think this is the first time
we are announcing
an entirely new game label new game
publisher
enjoy this first look at more than 12
games that make up
its initial slate
[Music]
sometimes i ask myself what what it all
means
let's begin
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
is that who you are my purpose
makes me who i am
[Music]
i finally have the feeling we're doing
something worthwhile being relied on to
succeed
where others would fail
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
prime matter
there you have it prime matter payday
3-2 and there is actually one more game
added to the mix and for that we go to
todd holland's head from
saber todd how you doing i'm great jeff
thank you for the intro there i'm really
excited to have this little
last edition which is is that saber and
prime matter are working together on a
new game in the painkiller franchise
all right very cool on that and there
are more details on prime matter coming
tomorrow with a stream at noon pacific 3
p.m eastern and i will be
stopping by next up is a brand new ip
from a brand new studio stray bombay
it's coming this fall only to xbox pc
and game pass on day one it's called the
anachrosis a four-player cooperative
first-person shooter
set aboard a massive starship stranded
at the edge of explored space
you team up with your friends in an
infinitely replayable fight against
alien hordes to unlock
perks weapons and new ways to play that
you can share with your team
here is the world premiere trailer
hello nasa
leo
lance get on
thanks no problem stick together and
let's do this
is this a disco
[Music]
this i do not like
[Music]
what if we open the doors and run
just run no stopping no shooting just
straight to the bridge
[Music]
heavy really we call them tanks i call
them brutes
from latin brutus we'd sound smart
calling them fruits
gion you don't want to get in here and
help name these no i'm good
awesome look thanks for that chet and
the team at stray bombay uh tomorrow
tune in to summer game fest for a
special deep dive presentation on new
world a
new open world mmo from amazon games
set on the supernatural island of
eternum it's finally coming out later
this summer and in the deep dive video
game director scott lane will take
players into the mysterious supernatural
island that is a world of wonder
and horror once you arrive it's up to
you to unite warring human factions to
take on a common common enemy
the tempest who wants to unmake life
scott and the team will detail
updates to the game including new mid
and end game content
more pve and expeditions five player
challenges with unique mechanics bosses
loot and more
six of these expeditions will be at
launch with the closed beta on july 20th
and the public launch on august 31st i
will also be down at the studio to chat
with scott about the game and the team's
efforts over the past year
in the midst of covid it is exciting for
me to finally be able to get out there
and visit game studios again i miss
all these developers so check out the
special deep dive stream on new world
tomorrow at 8 a.m pacific 11am eastern
at summergamefest.com
all right well back in 2018 rocket
league teamed up with fast and furious
bringing some of the saga's most iconic
cars into the game
and now they are back with a twist that
is truly rocket league
with fast nine the next installment of
the fast saga arriving in u.s theaters
june
25th psyonix is bringing back the nissan
skyline
dodge charger and well maybe the most
literal
supersonic acrobatic rocket-powered
heist car
ever conceived the f9 pontiac
fiero
[Music]
strap a rocket engine to a car and play
soccer
seems like the right idea to me the fast
and furious three-car bundle arrives
june 17th
in rocket league okay next up last year
a new swedish company named
shark mob released a teaser for their
first unnamed multiplayer project in the
vampire the masquerade universe
tonight we're putting a name on their
first game with a brand new
world premiere trailer
for centuries we have lived in secrecy
among you maintaining the masquerade
we have influenced your society
[Music]
fed on your blood
thrived among you
until now
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
i can't wait to play this game and we
actually won't have to wait long you can
sign up now
for the bloodhunt.com is where you go
for the closed alpha
pc test available on july 2nd blood hunt
will be released
later this year next the latest horror
game series from the creators of until
dawn continues with the house of ashes
part of the dark pictures anthology this
third game features american and iraqi
soldiers
stranded in a cursed temple here's the
story trailer with the exclusive reveal
of the monsters lurking in the depths
an ancient horror has awoken from its
slumber and is hungry for blood
shall we see how many have fallen into
shadow
satellite sweeps of the war zone have
uncovered what appears to be an
underground
storage facility but i strongly suspect
where chemical weapons are hidden so we
need to move fast
to descend into the unknown alone is
extremely brave
or extremely foolish
brothers in arms or will it be a case of
each man for himself
on the edge of an abyss
your survival depends on the choices you
make
they will be as a compass guiding you
through the
than we unknown what nightmare have
these luckless souls fallen
into you keep looking
look out look out for what
one by one their lights
will be snuffed up unless you can find
the means
to save them trapped beneath the earth
swallow we have to move let's go by the
boy
will you find the path to salvation
or be lost in the darkness
forever
[Applause]
one of the longest most beloved jrpg
franchises in the industry is the tales
of
series well the latest game arise was
announced two years ago
and it brings the franchise into
stunning 3d with unreal engine 4.
here's a world premiere look at the
latest trailer with more information
following in the coming weeks
pretty fancy place they got here harmony
and coexistence between the rennins and
the damans
i'm dilkaras should you need my skills
on the battlefield
all i care for is maintaining peace i'm
captain kisara of the el dominancia god
from now on when i fight i fight to
protect my dream
well this crew just gets bigger and
bigger
the renins seems the rumors you were
running with them were true
been looking for you
get the hell out of my realm this is
dannon's realm and it's ours understand
is it over it's only just begun
[Music]
for summer game fest we have a special
announcement for you
that the console version of sky children
of the light would arrive to nintendo
switch
on june 29th and the little prince
season would start soon after
on july 6th enjoy the game
[Music]
one of the things i take great pleasure
in is using a platform like this show to
introduce you to new developers and
studios
with games that deserve the spotlight
that's definitely the case with this
next title
from a small swedish studio named
wishfully planet of lana tells the story
of a young girl and her loyal friend
who embark on a mission through a
colorful world that's designed to feel
like a gouache
watercolor painting come to life here's
your first look
at the planet of lana coming to xbox and
pc
in 2022
hmm
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
what a beautiful artistic game honor to
have that on our show well joining me
now
is aaron keller who's the game director
of overwatch two aaron uh
great to have you here on kickoff live
thanks for joining us thank you so much
for having us here
yeah we are excited to learn more about
what's planned for overwatch 2. you guys
recently you had a pvp live stream that
i watched and you revealed some uh
some changes coming to overwatch too uh
what can you tell us what's the latest
yeah so we recently announced that
overwatch 2's format is changing to a
5v5 team format
this requires a fresh look at all of our
heroes in the game
it should feel new yet familiar
to fans of our strategic team-based
combat
yeah it was great to see you guys
playing and uh you know i
long awaited for people to get a chance
to go hands-on with it um
and today i know you brought us a look
at uh some skins for some of the uh some
of the characters right
yeah the team is so passionate about
updating the look
and the feel of the world of overwatch
and one aspect of that
is creating entirely new models for
overwatch too for all of our heroes
so today we're going to be looking at
two of those uh baptist and sombra
all right well let's take a look here
and i know you're going to tell us a
little about what we're seeing but uh
it's so cool to see these characters
brought into overwatch too so yeah what
do we got here
yeah so this is baptiste and there's a
lot of new technology that go into our
models
we have new share hater or hair shader
tech excuse me
um in order to to get the look that
we're going for with his haircut he also
has
a glowing cape and gloves that kind of
give that
medic or surgeon vibe to him
thank you and uh we're gonna sombra i
think yep so
next up is sombra this was a very
challenging look for us to update
there's it's an asymmetrical design
there's so many layers of hair
and clothing and technology in this if
you look closely you can actually see
circuitry and nodes embedded in her
clothing
she's a world-class hacker so it all
makes sense
no again it's you know so great for fans
to see these characters you know and
love
uh from the first game updated for
overwatch too
and we can't wait to see uh more on the
game we appreciate you giving us a
little sneak preview here and i'm sure
there'll be more later this year on
overwatch too
you bet thank you awesome all right
thanks very much erin uh now recently i
had a chance to play dungeons and
dragons dark alliance with the game
developer jeff adam
hannibal burris and ember moon from the
wwe that's right you didn't expect me to
say that
but this game is a ton of fun and it's
coming to game pass on june
22nd take a look
hey guys it's jeff keeley and today as
part of summer game fest we are going
hands-on with a game that is coming out
in just
a couple of weeks it is dark alliance
and
we've got jeff one of the game
developers from 2k jeff special guests
animal burris and ember moon okay
okay that looks like a trap
oh
oh no oh no i can't believe i'm down i'm
down people the developer's down
is down so amber i know you really
wanted to be drift absolutely
i've read all the books especially the
dress backstory and i just connected
with it on such an intimate level to the
point where
my wrestling character that everyone
sees on tv is actually based on this
character
the red eyes even though dress has
purple i just love everything about him
that he's just
constantly the good guy the entire time
oh oh what the
hell big chef ah that doesn't look
healthy at all oh why did i just run up
on him like this
let me see what you thought you ain't
got nothing on us baby i'm here now
oh wow
we don't want any dessert there you go
let's go damn what a death
gonna have some weird dreams tonight
because of that oh
act complete that was great
there's a bridge
[Music]
you take
[Music]
all right summer game fest kickoff live
presented by prime gaming continues
yesterday was an amazing tease of the
next battlefield from ea
and if you want to dust up on the
history of the franchise it's last big
modern day game
uh that was battlefield 4. it's this
month
prime gaming members get to download it
and play it for
free through june 20th now there's no
catch
this is the full-blown pc version of the
2013 game
and those only in battlefield moments
still hold up just head to
gaming.amazon.com to redeem your free
copy right now
if you are an amazon prime member and
this sunday watch the xbox and bethesda
game showcase
for the first gameplay footage of
battlefield 2042
going to be really cool um all right
right now let's take a look at another
world premiere
monster hunter stories is coming to the
switch in july
and we've got your first look at the
story trailer
we can't let you interfere with our
plans
[Music]
that's the monster red zone
[Music]
you suppose he saw this coming
we won't let you awaken it
[Music]
so you're going to be born huh
[Music]
next this legendary rock band hits the
road this summer on the hello mega tour
with green day and fallout boy
but first they came together with an
indie developer to create
stream safe music for the community yes
you can co-stream this performance
so turn it up premiering their brand new
never-before-release song
tell me what you want from wavebreak
this is weezer
this is a message that my manager
wouldn't
[Music]
don't be influenced by an officer
i won't mention any names
i'll write it down in my notebook
if it's gonna make you happy
i'll give you my guitar
show me
[Music]
i need a taste baker to tell me which
way to go
so i can play the halftime show at the
super bowl
everyone's entitled to their own
opinions
here's a big chance yeah you got the
next three
[Music]
what seconds want i'll write it down
in my
[Music]
you notebook guitar show me all yours
[Music]
hey baby should i bleach
if it's gonna make you happy
i'll give you my guitar
show me
that was so amazing uh thank you rivers
and guys for that both the song
and the game released tomorrow on pc
nintendo's switch music streaming
platforms twitch soundtrack
and a limited edition 7-inch vinyl on im
8-bit
all right well right now let's turn to a
game that we announced
last year at the game awards endless
dungeon from amplitude
we showed a brief glimpse of gameplay in
december and fans wanted more
well here's an extended look at endless
dungeon
we're stuck in this rack until everybody
[Music]
work better on certain monsters
learn it or die oh
option b then
rule number two use turrets to protect
that unstable dust bomb we call the
crystal
because it's their catnip
and if it goes you go
[Music]
yup just like that
rule number three watch your squat
even if you've got the guns the turrets
and the crystal
you can't do everything by yourself if
you fight alone
you die alone
uh together again and rule number four
well if you've got all that going but
you
still can't win
you gotta change the squad
[Music]
tag team i'm in
what are you guys doing tonight if
you're lucky enough to have a ps5 you're
probably getting ready to play ratchet
and clank rift apart i've been playing
it and having
a ton of fun well later today the team
at insomniac is going to be doing a
special
launch stream on twitch and to tell us
more take it away
marcus and mike hey jeff and everybody
watching summer games fest kickoff live
marcus smith here creative director at
insomniac games for ratchet and clank
rift apart
we're excited that players finally get a
chance to play the game tomorrow
and to celebrate want to spend some more
time with you today
at 2 p.m pacific 5 pm eastern
to live stream the first hour of rift
apart
isn't that right mike that's right i'm
mike daly the game director of rifter
park
in addition to playing through the
opening of the game we'll also be taking
your questions live and talking about
what it was like to develop the game
behind the scenes
so please join us at twitch.tv slash
insomniac games
at 2pm pacific 5 pm eastern
we'll see you there
[Music]
all right we're now about to be joined
by the one and only
john carlo esposito to talk far cry
6. john carlo thank you for joining us
why did you want to take on
this role they came to me with this
phenomenal idea
and had proposed that i play anton
castillo
the leader of yara with this big vision
and dream
for his country and it really appealed
to me because he was a guy who
first came from a love of his family and
a love of his
community and country and it was so in
in line with what's going on in the
world politically today
and what has happened in the past i
thought what a great opportunity
the other part of it is it's just a
different technology that's so brand new
it excites me as a filmmaker that i
wanted to be a part of it
all right well you've played some
absolutely amazing villains in your
career what was it like being
a video game villain no i'm not a
villain
i have to i gotta push back on you i'll
let you finish
but this guy loves his country
he wants to empower you keely he wants
to empower
you to stand up and speak your truth
now you can go back to calling me a
villain if you like well you are smiling
on the box you're a good guy right
i am because i i feel like we as human
beings fall in line
and i i want to be
a renegade within reason how do you like
that because i think
part and parcel of us falling in line
and doing what we need to do
and thinking about the cumulative effect
of our doing what's right and the
example of that is also to stand up
and say no i do agree that
they're good and bad about all people
but this guy out of his love and passion
for his people
even if they're faceless to him at
certain points in time
allow him to be an absolute hero
speaking of your character who did you
base him on or study to create this
character
it's so interesting because of course
the the obvious choice to study
is fidel castro and it is cuba
an island had so many resources but
really the
dream of the ability of the dictator to
cultivate those resources
something got in the way there and
hopefully that can change in the years
to come if funny you asked me that
question because i was just talking to
one of my daughters about
choices and and uh also hitler
uh because we were talking about zodiac
signs and
what signs for certain people what is
that mindset that has you
wanting to be have power over others uh
and for each dictator it's different
she'd never heard of trenches
and studied political science and all
this in college
so anyway so all right well one last
question for you uh
who would win in a square off between
gus fring
moff gideon and anton
you know and i have my favorites in
those two so you asked me this question
uh and and you know immediately
i say moff gideon immediately
you know somehow i i think gus is colder
and displays that coldness in a very
particular way
uh you know i think anton
could be the most violent man on earth
uh but given his situation he may not be
rise to that occasion
or may not have the time moff gideon is
otherworldly
this guy thinks in a different way and
he knows what you're thinking before you
say it
and he he does all his own dirty work
and he has
an incredible tool to help him out so
i'm going to say boss kitty
fair enough all right john carlo thank
you so much for hanging out with us
we will check out the revolution in far
cry 6.
and i can't wait for it to begin let the
games begin
awesome all right thank you so much john
carlo if you haven't picked up on it yet
prime gaming unlocks a ton of in-game
benefits for amazon prime members
like an exclusive valkyrie skin in apex
legends 200 000
in gta cash every week you play gta
online and in fall guys you get a
special
burning circuits costume for your bean
through june 21st
now speaking of fall guys the time has
come to reveal a brand new costume
coming to the game based on a legendary
game franchise
check it out
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
when a vision bearer dies the light in
their vision will fade away
organizing the clash is my way of
uncovering hidden talents
and hopefully this time getting a vision
to glow again your opponent is new to
the clash but he has quickly become the
dark horse of the tournament
the vision is missing the sounds of
nature turn into a clamor of noise
during stormy weather
the winds are coming clouds hide the
birds come
so today we've announced games a
publisher prime matter so why not
announce a developer two
and joining me now are dave anthony and
jason blundell from the newly formed
deviation
games uh we know you guys well from all
your amazing work over the years at
treyarch and call of duty black ops but
uh
what can we expect from your new studio
guys well thanks jeff
and uh look jason and i we've been mates
for donkey's years
and we're like an all-married couple
jeff and we've been working together for
decades
and we've worked on some huge franchises
you know the games you know they've done
well
and uh but we thought you know when
you're working on those franchises the
long-established ips you're working
within very very tight constraints
creatively about what you can do
so we thought after all these years you
know what if we deviated
so that's deviation games okay so jeff
just trust me
all bets are off from day one we got
complete financial security
yeah to work with creative freedom and
time
not just to make a brand new ip which is
what we're doing
but a groundbreaking new ip with
innovation
at its very core and the team at
deviation games the culture we have is
really
really simple it's there's no place for
ego
it's the best idea that always wins and
that's deviation games
all right well uh big ideas from you
guys as we would expect now i know it's
very early and uh
there is nothing to show on the game
today but can you tell us a bit
about what kind of game you're making
what can we expect yeah i mean you're
very right there jeff very early but um
a lot of exciting stuff going on so
essentially we spent the last year
building the team right and so what we
knew was we wanted to
collect passionate creative
collaborative people and bring them
together kind of under one roof and
that's what deviation games is so
yeah we don't have anything to show
right now but that collaboration that
imagination
is is going on and we're going to have
something that's going to uh i think
leave an indelible mark in the industry
when we come out
all right well uh with you guys involved
as i said we're excited about it there
is one more piece of the puzzle though
that you want to reveal
today and for that let's take a look at
[Music]
this
okay big news the stage has changed
blue of playstation so you're partnering
with uh with playstation what can you
tell us about that partnership that's
right jeff
and the partnership with playstation
it's all about quality
from soup to nuts this project is all
about quality
and our team of deviators that we have
back in the studio we're doing this for
you we are so proud of you
and um the partnership with sony it's
it's very very
simple i mean god just look at the track
record of consistency of high quality
games that they do
it's hit after hit it's award after
award and now we've been part of this
process and we see how
they do things it's really clear how
they're managing to accomplish that so
we couldn't be more proud
to expand playstation's portfolio which
we're going to do in a very very
significant way
i mean let's just face it right sony
rocks and they they get our kind of
branded crazy so we're very happy with
this partnership
all right so deviation games playstation
brand new ip a mega ip it sounds like
coming in the future and uh hopefully
we'll
see you guys again in the future to see
more on what you're working on thanks a
lot
awesome all right uh dave jason thank
you very much guys all right well this
year is the 30th anniversary of sonic
the hedgehog and later this month
we are honored to be premiering the full
sonic symphony performance
but right now here's the philharmonic
orchestra in prague
performing the music of sonic unleashed
[Music]
love orchestra music all right sunday
warner brothers games and turtle rock
will be giving players a new look
at the zombie multiplayer fun of back
for blood and right now we've got a
quick tease of a new boss
and news on the beta coming later this
summer
all of my best friends
[Music]
until i'm too late
one of the things i'm most passionate
about is getting you guys access to play
more games at home
last year steam and xbox did incredible
demo events around summer game fest and
this year
steam's next fest starts next wednesday
and xbox
is back again to do an idiot xbox demo
event which i'm announcing right now
it starts on tuesday and it's completely
free
no badge is required one of the games
i'm most excited
about in the lineup is tunic from my
fellow canadian andrew shoulders
here he is to give you a little sneak
preview of the brand new demo
which you can exclusively play on xbox
starting on tuesday
hi my name is andrew scholdice and i'm
working on tunic
which is an isometric action adventure
about a tiny fox in a big world
where you explore the wilderness fight
monsters and find secrets
i first started working on it about six
years ago
and uh it's been changing a lot over the
years but
uh i'm really excited about where we've
gotten into today
so in tunic you you start the game and
you are a little fox that's
washed up on a beach and you don't have
a whole lot of context except for
you know a lust for adventure and you
are going to wander off and maybe you're
going to find a
stick and maybe if you venture a little
bit further maybe you're going to find a
sword
it's really about that sense of
discovery about
wondering what's around the next corner
people have played the game
at shows before but we wanted to put
together a brand new demo
that was you know for the home audience
and so it's full of never-before-seen
stuff a brand new dungeon a bunch of
areas people haven't seen before
so excited about tunic and sable also uh
is going to be one of the games in that
along with a lot of other awesome titles
so check that out next week
on xbox uh next up stave off ragnarok in
this ancient norse inspired co-op
action survival rpg that you can also
fully play solo
classic hack and slash gameplay goes
viking in norse fell's tribes of midgard
launching on playstation and pc july
27th
here is the brand new trailer
the giants have come to midgard and you
have been chosen by the gods to protect
israel
but your first task is to find some new
clothes that aren't
droppedy your tribe's journey starts in
the wilderness
to hunt down pets gather rare resources
and explore the untamed world
once you've plundered all you can carry
return to your village and use those
resources to forge viking worthy gear
you must protect the seed of yggdrasil
at all costs
for this world and everything in it will
be destroyed forever
so take heed ahead things rise when the
sun sets
destroy these dark spirits before they
destroy the seed
each victorious night makes way for a
new day
to venture into new lands live to
greater heights
and face fiercer creatures and with
great risk comes great rewards
but be careful you're a little used to
midgard squashed by a troll
craft legendary weapons build deadly
defenses
and throw the strength of your tribe
because those giants are on their way
and it's time for us to end their path
of destruction
let's show them our might is greater
than their height
as the saying goes valhalla
can't wait
who's ready for some evil dead we
announced this game last december at tga
and now it's time for an extended look
at the gameplay
to tell us more let's turn it over to my
friend tim willits from sabre
hi jeff it's great to see you today
we have some extended footage of the
evil dead
the game we are excited to show you
this and to help me explain it is bruce
campbell
thank you
oh
hola cyber friends i'm bruce campbell
you know me as ash williams the dude who
saved the world from evil
i'm here to bring you the lowdown on the
upcoming evil dead the game
you and your friends will team up as
classic evil dead heroes to live the
nightmare
you'll use savage finishing moves or
tear evil a new one
or if you're not into the whole save the
world thing
we have another option
[Music]
you can play as the vile candarian demon
itself
but who would want to do that he'd be a
dick with the power of possession in
your arsenal
you'll scare those goody two shoes to
death literally
you can do that if you're a dick
whether you choose the path of evil or
righteousness
you'll be throwing down in places you've
seen before
you'll collect pages of the necronomicon
uncover nobody's lost tapes
track down other legendary artifacts
you've grabbed enough you'll use a spell
to send the kendarian son of a [ __ ]
back to the hell hole
it came from
soon you'll experience the horror
yourself but for now i'll leave you with
this thought
it was no accident that ash always wore
brown pants
oh
[Music]
i'll spoil those goods
okay guys now it's time
for the grand finale to the show this
is extremely special today i am so
deeply honored to be given the
opportunity to share this next game
it comes from one of our industry's most
acclaimed developers
and a previous game of the year winner
at the game awards
i want to personally thank this
developer for believing in my vision of
summer game fest as a new way
to bring all of us together for a
cross-industry showcase
and kick off the summer in the right way
so without further ado please
sit back and enjoy this truly
spectacular
world premiere it is
finally time
the tarnished
will soon return
guided by grace once lost
the golden order is broken to its core
foul tarnished
in search of the elden ring
emboldened by the flame of ambition
someone must extinguish
thy flag
they will fight and they will die
in an unending curse
a lowly tarnished
playing as a lord
brandish the elden ring
for all of us
it actually happened eldon ring
is coming as you saw january 21st 2022
to next gen current gen it's so
incredible and i want to thank so much
miyazaki-san and the team at from for
sharing that
in-game look at eldon ring i hope you
guys are happy oh my god i'm free
out of prison all right uh and that's
gonna do it for summer game fest kick
off live
thank you so much to all the developers
who took part and for you
and watching around the world it means
so much to me summer game fast
continues all weekend with netflix
geeked week and prime matter tomorrow
ubisoft forward on saturday and xbox and
bethesda on sunday
square enix as well head to
summergamefest.com for the full and
complete schedule and this is really
just
the kickoff to summer and a ton of other
amazing events
that i'm fully supportive of and i'm
very excited to see what they have in
store for us as well
as for me i'll see you again on august
25th
for gamescom opening night live and this
december
i am so happy to say that the game
awards will return as an
in-person ceremony at the microsoft
theater in los angeles
more details are coming later this
summer thanks again for being a part of
summer game fest we will see you
tomorrow for more
and stay tuned for the day of the devs
with i am 8bit and double fine
right now good night everybody
well there you have it tam you were
right all along
eldon ring how do you feel
i um i have been through so many
emotions
i went from what the hell is tunic to
nobody is ready for evil dead
no one cares to like absolutely elated
that trailer was incredible like i i
am so ready to get off this stream and
just
pour over it frame by frame and we got a
january release date
january yeah that is did you think it
would be
i was gonna say how how uh in line with
your expectations did you find that
released
did you think it would be later i
thought it would be later because of
covid
um but i am pleasantly surprised i
i i it should have been out this year
um but it was delayed because of various
circumstances
and now it's i thought it was going to
be like maybe
middle of next year but it's it's
january and
holy [ __ ] it looks so good oh my god
january is a wonderful release date
like nothing comes out in january we'll
be able to focus on like
this game the same way that we kind of
were able to focus on like hitman 3
for like a month this year oh it's
wonderful nothing but elven ring content
coming nothing but elven ring content
coming james what will be becoming a
full-time elden ring
website well that was going to happen
regardless of what month it came out
what were these
yeah i mean like well there's there's so
much to unpack there but the thing that
really stuck out with me is
it genuinely looks like an amalgamation
of everything they've done so far to a
degree
there's things in there that look like
sakura combat with the
with the uh kind of hitboxes and the
types of encounters that you that they
made
there's like open world elements with
that character
summoning a wraith horse and then
like riding up a mountain that looked
ridiculous there's like the bonfire in
the middle of like just a wilderness
area
it looks like the character is just
traveling
from area to area in a massive open
world the dragon
that dragon looks sick there's a bit
where
there's a bit where like there's a red
lightning bolt
and it looks like the lightning bolts
from the celestial dragon in sakura
and it's just like oh my god everything
that like
thus far that they have worked on feels
like it somehow made it into this game
and i am over the moon about it it looks
so so good and like they have one of the
not criticisms one of the things about
it was their design was
especially in the souls games were
starting to become quite
familiar they had very archetypal
monster and also like enemy designs and
this looks so so different now there's
like that one
you know multi-armed enemy there's that
weird like
ethereal reindeer which has got like big
dancer of the boreal valley uh
kind of um energy there's that one scene
which looks like it was taking
this one fight taking place like in
amongst this like graveyard which
has huge father gas coin uh energy
and it looks like yeah it's just looking
incredibly special right now obviously i
want to temper my expectations
um but what i'm seeing of it is is very
very very exciting i'm ready to be
obsessed by another song i need
another from software game you don't
know how
this is like going to redefine my life
for the next year and a half so
i i'm so glad that what if it had come
out and it had been like
yeah looks okay that would have been
devastating to me because i know that i
want to pour over these games and i want
to spend
you know like many others out there in
the community this is going to be the
thing that we
really put our energy and care and
attention into whether you're playing it
or
making videos doing law things just
being obsessed by it and if it had come
out and
trailer looked like uh looks kind of
okay looks at more dark souls
that would have been devastating but it
came out and what we saw was genuinely
like
jaw-dropping stuff and genuinely amazing
stuff and
the i'm sorry i'm just going on but like
i'm speaking
like i don't know what kind of uh import
george rr martin had but like the amount
of
things interesting things whether
they're like words
the names of people places the factions
the environments they look so diverse
that
the how that whole world comes together
as a
a whole and as a like a symbiotic thing
as a one
thing that exists in this one universe
how all that exists in this one universe
is going to be fascinating to unpack
until now from software has gone into
like these kingdoms and
places and they've all had this kind of
through line throughout them where
there's like an aesthetic or a a
thematic thing that connects them
together you know and janam it's blood
and this victorian style thing in
the souls games there's high fantasy to
some degree nights and that kind of
stuff
this looks like it's all over the place
and when when you've got so many like
diverse sporadic ideas and themes
that just means there's more
opportunities for item descriptions and
stories to connect it all together in an
interesting way
and it just looks like the most from
software game that from software has
ever made
the stuff that i'm really interested in
seeing more of however is like how does
it play
because they fundamentally you know
they've gone through different styles of
play with the souls games and then
bloodborne and then sakura
um so how does i i imagine it's gonna
all come together and i love the idea
that it seems like you can pick up a
samurai sword or a blade that's similar
to it and
you're mechanically playing a secular
game kind of
or you pick up a broadsword and it feels
like dark souls
but there's also like other weapons that
we saw in there like
a bunch of different unique new weapons
that one energy blade that became this
massive sword
like the magic looks like it's gonna be
i feel like magic's gonna be the big
thing for this game like they have
that's the one thing that has been
fairly
like underdeveloped not underdeveloped
but like it's the thing that they
haven't really pushed to a
to its furthest degree a year and i feel
like this is the game where they really
do that and
ah it just looks good man it looks good
it feels good i feel like i've
unclenched
after years of waiting now and it feels
good man it feels good
i mean you've sort of very eloquently
especially given how excited you are
i have kind of gone over what my initial
thoughts of it i just
you kind of there's i don't think there
are many developers who can immediately
sweep you into a very specific place
just as easily as from software does and
as soon as that trailer started i think
you know the hair on my
arms was kind of up a little bit because
i was like oh this is it this is finally
going to be elden ring and i think
you know ever since that teaser was it
two years ago now
the hype around it has been so intense
we've all
obviously just wanted to see more of it
and
i didn't realize we'd kind of see that
much because like you said there is so
much more to it like you you use the
phrase all over the shop and i
i would use that too but not in a
negative way i think it just you know is
an expansion of everything that from
software has done
and i'm very very excited about the
possibilities uh in terms of gameplay in
terms of level design and
especially in terms of creature design
that that's going to afford them so i'm
i'm very excited i just i can't wait to
see how it all
fits together and
and particularly i mean obviously the
your interest is going to be peaked with
the george rr and stuff but i am
like both him and from software
and miyazaki just masters of building
worlds
and ultimately like that's the stuff
here you love dark souls and
bloodborne for the combat and the kind
of visceral nature of it but really
the community when you play it you love
digging into the lore that they've built
and uncovering the secrets behind it and
so i can't wait to see
what they've put together for this
jordan what about you
i would say i kind of in the same place
you all are i'm like man they showed us
so much gameplay way more gameplay than
i had anticipated them actually
showing uh i'm i'm already trying to
like dig
through like screenshots and the
symbolism and words that they use like
it seems like the main character is
called the tarnished which i'm like
okay what what could that possibly mean
like all of the
main characters for the souls games have
had like some sort of
nickname that like comes back with some
greater meaning by the time you
finish it so what could something like
the tarnish mean i'm
really interested in seeing how exactly
the world and level design
for this plays out because dark souls
bloodborne secure a lot of their
environments that are like specifically
designed to encourage the players to
encounter enemies in very
specific ways sometimes in a very
specific
order so i'm like i'm looking at the
open world and we're seeing moments
where you're
exploring but like you're also exploring
and there seems to be
instances where kind of funnels the
player like into either
bridges or canyons and stuff like that
so
is this like an open world game scope
similar to resident evil
village where like there's an open part
but you're like going to very
clear set piece areas or is this truly
like completely open world where it's
like you can
get into these giant spaces that connect
to all these other different areas that
you can tackle in whatever
order you want like what does that look
like how does that influence how combat
plays out if at all how do you balance
for something like that like that's what
i really want to see
next jordan it says the tarnished
will soon return are you the tarnished
or are you someone
who is preparing for the tarnish return
i mean maybe
but i feel like the tarnished is who the
main character is but again it's from
software they they
love to do the whole like subverting
thing
the goal is to say this for the next
seven months
yes yes what does it mean
oh man this is just us until january now
we should probably talk about that
i'm going to be insufferable stop
playing the b-roll john
it's gonna make we want to keep talking
about it
any
he reminded me a little bit of um the
uh the big tortoise in god of war a
little bit
except he had a house underneath him and
a giant bell and i suppose
and the big taught us in avatar the last
bender
and on foot look we're doing a live show
um all right let's talk about the rest
of the show so it should be said that uh
day of the devs is also happening so we
are also running that on a separate
stream if you do want to watch it's a
collection
of indie games pulled together by double
fine and i am 8-bit
um it's an event that usually happens i
think twice a year now um so if you want
to go check that out we have the stream
or if you want us
to just watch our reactions to summer
game
fest then stick around here so we should
probably go through the show
uh overall what did you think jordan
of this year's summer game fest the
overall show
um i
it was very like exciting up front i
adored seeing
a tiny tina's wonderlands i can't wait
to see what that was about
metal slug tactics i think that's what
it was called
that game i was not expecting to ever
see
metal slug game again especially in a
tactical
setup whatever hideo kojima was
doing with that interview where he
was like mentioning 911 and then it
crossed into
death stranding and there was all those
male gear stuff like all of that like it
was this huge exciting opening i felt
like it
might have like dragged like a little
bit midway
through as like the show was going on
and going on i feel like it was going a
little bit longer than it probably
wanted to and then just we got that
elden ring at the very end i'm like ah
this this is what we've been sticking
around for this is what i'm excited for
good ending good ending so let's talk
about those uh those announcements from
the very beginning uh let's kick off
with wonderland's then because that was
the big show opener so we did know
uh that this game was coming i don't
think we realized this sort of scope of
it
i assumed it would just kind of be more
borderlands
uh but it's actually seems that it's a
little bit different obviously more high
fantasy
um this could be spell casting and you
can customize your own character
uh jordan as our resident borderlands
fan are you excited for this one uh what
what's peaked your interest
i really wish we could have seen
gameplay just to kind of see what those
differences
look like play out i'm kind of worried
they're like oh it's completely
different from borderlands don't worry
like there are spells now i'm like i
feel like
spells are just what the new grenades
are but
we have to wait we have to see what that
looks like the cinematic we saw
was really dope and i'm excited to see
tiny tina again especially in the
capacity of
a narrator uh her role and uh
the tiny tina's assault and dragon keep
dlc in borderlands 2 was
phenomenal and we got like a bunch of
great storytelling there she was like
struggling to wrap around the grief of
losing a
father figure and like that playing out
in a dungeons and dragon game like i
i want to see that i want to see that
type of story
i i just i don't i don't know what the
game actually
is like they made like jeff was like oh
it's the new borderlands game and then
they made a point of being like no this
is not borderlands it's its own thing
and i'm like those are
two different messages that i'm getting
here and i just i want a little bit of
clarification
well hopefully we'll be seeing more uh
at the gearbox event but what do you
make of that cast because obviously
you've got ashley birch reprising her
role as tiny tina but then
will arnett andy samberg uh
tim did you expect borderlands to get
this kind of star treatment
i didn't expect well i kind of expected
borderlands would eventually get the
star
treatment it's growing in like it's
become more and more successful as it's
gone along and the profile of it has
grown
i feel like it's also kind of reached a
point where it's got enough clout behind
it where
you know putting out a a kind of uh
a game that is got on all star cast is a
little easier especially when there's a
movie coming out around the same
franchise um easier to sell that i like
the
choices that they've made for who's in
the game um
mainly andy sandberg because i i like
andy sandberg a lot
um but yeah i think i think it's it
speaks
it speaks to a kind of ambition to
borderlands that i'm
excited to see it has has i'm you know
in the pre-show i said i wanted
something different and it feels like a
fantasy borderlands which is like
i feel like that's enough for me to to
get me in and
then the kind of voice cast and the um
the kind of
andy sandberg element the andy sandberg
x factor is enough to
be like yeah i'll i'll put something
down for that
i i just i want it on record now
because i want to make this bet i
guarantee you a mission will be set in a
place called the lonely island
i guarantee it yeah that would guarantee
that it would be nice i don't want to
i don't want to take that because i
might i'm pretty sure i'd lose
yeah i mean it's i'm a huge fan of uh
high fantasy stuff and so that
immediately got me interested i'm
excited to see one hopefully we will
definitely see more this weekend uh we
talked a little bit about metal slug
um but let's let's go into that
kojima interview um i don't think anyone
had
covid 911 and
hitler on their um e3 bingo cards
but they were all covered in this uh
this press conference
uh summer game fest show um
i i mean i guess what were your
reactions to the death stranding
director's cut
slash very strange metal gear solid
riff midway through the trailer i was
just like i'm gonna have to wait for tam
to just explain what all of this
yeah i mean like i feel like the the the
uh
very at the moment it started like it
was maybe two seconds into it i
and you convert from me i said that's
metal gear music and
yeah you did it and then and then it
immediately started doing metal gear
stuff and i was like
okay what's going on here because
there's no way there's metal gear
happening in death stranding
but what what is the deal here it's just
a director's cart which i know
lucy you pointed out kind of hilariously
uh that
um the whole point of just surrounding
was that it was
he was like un unmuzzled like he this
was
he was unshackled this was the main
version of death stranding is the
director's cut so i don't know what else
is going on here but
i'm excited to see yeah to see what what
um changes
he the team continuing productions has
made to death surrounding i'm super keen
to
play that game like i didn't get all the
way through it um i would love to know
when that is out so i can
plan because it's it's currently one of
the games i've
started replaying um so i would love to
check that out
the actual discussion about what he was
talking about
is kind of it's tricky right because
like kojima he talks to designing games
in a way that to him it makes a lot of
sense and to the people who like his
games and have kind of
tuned themselves slightly a bit more to
understand his way of thinking it makes
a lot of sense
but if you're like just listening to
this dude talk about his game ethos and
he's talking about
you know 911 and that kind of stuff it
can sound a bit weird and corny but the
at the end of the day his message is
like he's you know he created death
stranding in a world pre-culved and then
it came out and it just so happened to
align
with kovid right and it was like coming
at a time when
it's a game about making connections the
hoop and the stick and helping
people building togetherness and
forging that path you know using
technology and
the internet to bring people closer
together physically this game
came out at a time when the world was
forcing us to do the opposite
um or it exists in a time when the the
the world is forcing us to the opposite
it came out shortly before that but a
lot of people would have played it
during that period as well
so i think he's just being super aware
of what is the message and what kind of
game does he what kind of energy does he
want to put out into the world now
and it feels like he's trying to do
something you know he's done pmc's he's
done the state of
you know what the war of the world and
the war economy and the war engine of
the world and
i think he's seems like he's drifting
towards something a little more positive
and we had
kojima do stuff a little more um outside
of that wheelhouse
with stuff like boktai and
a person who's you know the head of a
studio
you know game for the com
channel we've had so far to this point
and it definitely feels like some
positivity and something a little more
uplifting
is on the cards and that's exciting
because it means that he's going to do
something different everyone's always
kind of
until this point said he's going to do a
horror game because
silent hills was the thing that they
started and del toro was involved and
jinji ito was involved and so i imagine
everyone imagines they're going to pick
pick up again this is perhaps the best
that speech was perhaps the best case
that a horror game in the
vein of silent hill with junji ito and
del toro might not be the thing he's
thinking about purely because
it's not the kind of energy he wants to
put out into the world right now
um so it definitely had purpose but
maybe i am
like fully uh leaning into this too hard
and like
reading far too much into it but that's
what i do when it comes to kojima and
and various other things well that's the
thing i mean
if he if he is gonna i mean given how
prescient uh
death stranding ended up being i for one
would love it for him to do something a
little more positive and maybe
you know the world will follow through
with that just like it did with death
stranding
uh so we'll go through some of the other
bigger announcements from the show so
obviously jeff goldblum was there
and i suppose we could have predicted
that he was there to announce uh
jurassic park evolution
ii um but we also had you know the call
of duty announce was a bit
i mean it's just it's more you know
season four of call of duty
it's it's not an announcement for me uh
but it was
you know cool to see joanna ferries up
there
um did you do you get anything out of
call of duty
i mean like i'm glad they put the the
lad from army of two into call of duty
great job on that um otherwise like
tim the tatman is gonna be a team leader
for something
he seems cool i like him a lot um when i
watch his stuff
call of duty yeah
i mean it's it's it's a behemoth it's
you know it's
cool of g is going to call of duty right
now i think for me everyone and
probably a lot of people are just
waiting for uh the brand new one that
sledgehammer games is making but we did
it was it was nice to see a little clip
of it here today
uh ryan reynolds with the elden ring
reference out of the gate i wonder how
much of that he was primed to do
or if he genuinely came up with that on
his own but i mean
a ready player one esque movie with
taika waititi
and uh villanelle from killing eve those
cool i think i think ryan reynolds is a
huge get for something like summer game
first like
i can see the the a-list is more at game
awards which is typically the sort of
bigger show of the year but it was
it was cool for them to reveal that one
here
i loved him in two guys a girl and a
pizza place
um and i'm glad to see he is continuing
to thrive since then
i um re-watched waiting
quite recently waiting hasn't been
married or what
it's still a very it's still a good film
funny but it doesn't it has a nature um
so i'm just gonna go through because we
had a lot of quick hits of things like
things like among us
they teased a lot like new roles colors
skins cosmetics
now they've got achievements they teased
the map but it was
literally a square and i mean
really that's fair because airship was
only only at the game awards right so i
guess like every six months between
um to be expected um
yeah but then you get other stuff like
chivalry and valorant and
tarkov um what did you think of
two-point campus
i mean it's it's still it's still too
soon for me to go back to college
like it looks like a great game it looks
like it looks as fun as two point
hospital where it's like oh i get to
micromanage everything that's
totally my type of game but i don't know
there was just something about like
seeing like the whole college campus and
the activities that students can do and
like
grading them on their papers and trying
to make sure that your college makes
enough
money so that it can stay open for
another semester i'm like
i don't know this is bringing back
emotions that i really didn't want to
feel again
i'm still paying like my student loans
i'm 100
gonna be taking out all my anger and
stress at my about my college on
whatever college i build in this in this
in this
game i'm just going to be like i'm going
to drive these students into the ground
and make them work you're a monster
that's that's right that's my favorite
college is about you've become what you
hate
big college yeah i loved the guy who's
dressed in the night armor hiding weed
in his wardrobe i thought that was very
very funny very college experience
what dressed as a night rolling through
pots
yeah so one two one game that i yeah
one game that i really enjoyed uh the
look of i mean even though it was kind
of like a pre-rendered thing
not much gameplay if any at all but uh
blood hunt
set in the vampire the masquerade uh
universe um playing as i don't know it
was like a vampire multiplayer game
supernatural abilities i love vampires
not in a twilight way
i just think they're cool um yeah i
enjoyed
i mean it's it's difficult to kind of
get a real sense of what a multiplayer
game
is gonna be like especially when you're
looking at a pre-rendered trailer like
this one but if the aesthetic
from this matches the final game
i'll be quite happy yeah
it looks it looks cool i mean um i'm
glad to see that the vampire the
masquerade kind of universe is getting
fleshed out in a bit more i mean like we
had bloodlines
years and years and years ago and that
game was fantastic
but it's like very difficult to play
these days
um but yeah it feels like another one of
those universes that's just like
ripe for exploring and i'm glad it's
being done
i don't know if this is the the approach
that is going to hook me but i'm at the
very
least interested and intrigued enough by
it to definitely check it out i want to
sign up for that closed beta
um and it's out next is out this it's
out this year right or
yeah it's 2021 2021 yeah so
um yeah good job looks cool
uh we've got an updated look at two
overwatch heroes
i right tam and i are huge overwatch
fans
and i appreciate that overwatch 2 is not
gonna be
i don't believe it's coming out this
year uh they've been pretty cagey about
when it's coming out
the stuff they're announcing for it um
they kind of had like a big a ton of
stuff to announce previously you know
like a new mode push uh the fact that
it's now 5v5
i'm kind of not digging these reveals
of just like hey here's the character
you've known and played
um for the past few years here's how
they look in the new game
whereas you have that game you have
overwatch one that is just languishing
because there's really not that much new
content coming for it because
you assume most of the dev team is on
overwatch too so
that's my that's my overwatch gripe i
know that uh in the interview you did
with him with
aaron keller time he said like stuff
will be coming to overwatch one
it felt like this could have been a good
place to announce something for
overwatch one it's still
a popular game it's still great it has
cross play now
but still you know cross play and
events with new skins
come on i feel like the only thing worse
than no news
is news that feels insignificant and
as much as i love overwatch i'm getting
like
it's getting slightly annoying that the
only thing that we're seeing
is one or two characters in their new
looks
like it it kind of it's anti-hype like
you can't get
excited about one character like i don't
play baptiste
i think sombra's fine but like looking
at that i was like
it's not really like and like if they
had shown me zarya i think i would have
been like a little more excited but
still not as excited i just want like a
one big
you know this is our avengers moment
where we're gonna reveal
every single person from the old game in
their new look and it pans around them
and you can be like oh it's amazing
something more substantial and if
they're going to keep showing off or
talking about overwatch obviously it's
in the interest as a marketing you know
kind of a plan to do
frequent often beats all around it but
like you got to give us something more
like
attach a second or two five seconds of
gameplay to it or you know
give us a new voice line or a cool
animation that isn't
dancing or whatever like i i need a
little more
than what we're getting out of overwatch
like obviously as lucy you mentioned
like we play a crap ton of overwatch
so i'm excited about that anyway just
give me a little more to you know
to to choose
yeah it's probably hard though like how
many
teams like it's not like what activision
is doing with call of duty where it's
like oh we have many
developers many studios working on
different call of duty games
so we can keep updating the old ones
while working on the new ones like if
you look at something like
like overwatch is basically what
happened to like
titanfall and apex where eventually just
one day titanfall 2 just kind of
died and there was no more new content
for it and then years later apex legends
came out
like at some point i feel like blizzard
just has to say like hey
nothing else is coming to overwatch one
for a
while that's the thing is that stuff
from overwatch 2
is gonna be playable for folks with
overwatch one it's a very confusing
way that it's shifting it's not like
overwatch 2 is a clear-cut sequel
i guess the pvp is that i feel like it
should have been
heroes whatever the heroes and maps and
stuff
are going to be playable for overwatch
one players so it's like this weird
no man's land where the stuff that
they're talking about for overwatch two
yes theoretically will be playable with
overwatch one right but it's like
nothing's happening with bass overwatch
one until that new stuff happens and so
it's
very weird um and even though we should
probably move on because that
overwatch segment was only like 30
seconds within uh
some games i think i like the valerian
section was shorter
that was uh good grief
that was a very very short one wasn't it
um
we've been we've been going for half an
hour so i'm gonna slowly sort of wrap
things up we had a giancarlo esposito
um lovely house
lovely house loved his pelvis in the
living room
that's bold that's bold that's some
uh gav murphy moves uh a friend of mine
that was
on his on his exercise bike watching uh
summer game first
but yeah i mean it was as we expected
talking about far cry 6. i
did anticipate seeing some gameplay but
i guess we just
had a conversation about how the
dictator is not doesn't really see
himself as a villain
which i i suppose i understand his
line of thinking about that but it was a
very kind of a strange conversation i i
guess i kind of expected
gameplay i i want to see him talking to
kojima now
after that those two discussions
wild conversation well that's the thing
if this was in person imagine them being
in the green room
together just having it having a chat
um back for blood we're going to be
seeing more of on sunday so
we'll talk about that then um i
was very surprised to see tunic so tunic
is a game uh that i played
gamescom 28th i want to say yeah i don't
think i was there in 2019.
um i genuinely thought it would come out
um
apparently not but it still looks cute
it looks great like i'm very excited to
play it
i'm just so surprised because it feels
like it's one of those games that you
just see over and over again and
everyone's so hyped for it but it hasn't
come out yet
um jordan what do you think about tunic
i
i feel really bad like i i think steve
is the one who's
really looking forward to tunic like he
excitedly put a tweet into the slack
channel
like four months ago it's like oh the
tunic twitter account like tweeted out
an image and it's like the tunic
fox in front of like a golden door which
might mean that the game's gone gold and
we're getting it soon
and then they just went radio silent so
it's it's like you said it's one of
those things it's like 12 minutes where
it's just kind of been
in the e3 hype cycle for a few
years now and i don't know i was really
excited when it was first
announced and now i'm looking at it and
i'm like just
just come out like just show us
what you are you've been trying to hype
me up on what you've been for
three years now and i just i just want
to play you i just want to see what game
this is
and finally let's talk a little bit
about evil dead um
obviously we were all a bit bereft
because we thought it was going to be
elderly
but i thought it looked really really
cool i think it generally looked cool it
definitely had
uh the sort of dead by daylight vibes
especially when he was like yeah you can
play as the demon if you want to be a
son of a [ __ ]
uh if you want to be if you want to be a
dick and i
kind of i enjoyed that because i that's
you know i play a lot you're related you
know
because i like to be a menace so i i
also i was surprised at how gory it was
well not really surprised i was
surprised that it was this gory in this
show because the show hadn't been very
gory up until
this moment i guess but it looks great
um any any thoughts from you too
evil that's kind of a franchise that
kind of
passed me by a little bit like i i've
i've
i've enjoyed it i've partaken in it but
this this game's not on
my radar so to speak it's one of those
i'm like oh cool
this is an awesome looking horror game
that looks kind of
like dead by daylight only like a little
bit
gorier i'll probably play it but it's
not like
one of my most anticipated for the year
or something like that
yeah i think i think it looks i think it
looks really cool like
i know this is a a bad pull in terms of
the the experience it provided for us
but like
i've really enjoyed playing these kind
of like um asymmetrical multiplayer
games
like the dead by daylight what's the
other one that we played with
uh the lads did you play the
jason one the friday 13th one yeah
friday the 13th
oh and we played predator predator yeah
predator
hunting ground so we played a lot of
predator with like greg and andy over
kind of funny and that crew and i'm
i'm excited for when it comes out and
everyone
that in my circles are like playing it
and we all jump in together
and check it out and see if it's any
good because i know that even if it's
like
mediocre we'll get a decent amount of
fun out of it
my hope is and it looks this way it
looks a little more polished than
predator was and even um friday the 13th
was when it came out
so um i'm i'm actually quite into this
and you know
greg miller and andy cortez and uh
daniel cooper joe scrubbles let's you
know hit me up when this is out let's
let's party let's do
let's do some gaming why are you using
our show to do a little bit of
networking and matchmaking
lfg on the internet
well that about does it for our summer
game first
post show thank you tam and jordan and
thank you all for watching
uh as a part of gamespot's playful we're
gonna be back again tomorrow tom and i
will be joined by
mason downey from our entertainment team
for netflix geeks we saw a little bit of
a preview
as a part of summer game fest obviously
jeff is going to be hosting some of it
so
expect updates on things like the
witcher season 2
castlevania and according to jeff's
trailer
splinter cell so got some big questions
about that baby sound fish is not dead
after all
maybe maybe he's back in pog form
so we'll be on again tomorrow morning 8
30
a.m p.t uh show starts at nine
so join us then and have a good rest of
the day we'll see you tomorrow
hello ring baby
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
bye
[Music]
you